[Music]
the digital economy and society index
also known as desi measures the progress
of eu countries towards digitalization
through four key areas
since 2014 we have been sending out our
best team on a field trip across europe
to check out how digitalization is
coming along
meet helena klaus kasha enzo and marion
the index is composed of four areas that
group over 30 indicators overall first
how good is the fixed and mobile
broadband coverage how expensive is it
anyone got a good connection here
then how skilled are people with digital
and how digital is the business world
finally how rapidly are e-government
services growing
digital opens a world of possibilities
the eu measures the index to help
countries understand and compare their
progress
this allows continuous improvements of
european citizens digital experience
you can call me
matrix master and keep them connected
wherever they are
hey i get it it's exactly like
eurovision am i right
idesy carries out the same exercise at
the global level okay
like eurovision only bigger europe is
already competing on a global level but
with idesy we can find out how to do
even better
daisy who